see hi guys I've gotta say
congratulations on your first comic-con
we've got this gigantic building
billboard dedicated to you when you look
back and see that what's your initial
reaction Wow complete shock yeah it's
it's amazing I mean we were talking
about just how proud we were prior bit
and at the same time you like the
pressure involved with it I mean we
haven't even premiered and there's just
so much love and support and the fan
base is amazing Susan it feels good it's
great you're continuing on the sons of
anarchy legend what do you want to tell
the fans out there new fans and old what
should they know before they tune in to
Mayans and Z I mean I would say you
expect a different world but the same
universe I didn't say that has
eloquently
I will say this right as the Sons of
Anarchy found myself I will tell you
that I've read the scripts and just as a
fan like a continuing fan I'm just I'm
in awe of these scripts I mean all of
these people these powerful wonderful
diverse people and it's been a really
it's been an honor to play and it's just
it's it's just such a continuation of
that life you know it's like the camera
is on the sons of anarchy and and their
club and what they're going through and
it's almost as if like the it just kind
of switches like the camera just moves
over to the mind but of course since it
is in the same universe of sons of
anarchy we want to get to know the new
characters - but does that mean that
there's room for some maybe some
familiar faces to cross over it does
appear and he's the glue that cements
the sons of anarchy with the mayans and
he was part of the president of the
north northern california chapter but
our minds are the southern california
chapter on the border you guys talk to
me a little bit about the skills you've
been needing to learn in order to play
these characters how are your bike
skills at this point first of all we
just have to have balance like in
general and then getting on a bike no
but the bikes are definitely daunting at
first you know we got it yeah and then
the the fighting and I think the most
challenging part is just getting my butt
ready
you know jack shines but you know it's
all about his but Jax's blood so
[Music]
wait so location to the gym like
deadlifts squats and it's always have
you heard from any of the sun's cast I'm
sure I've we've already all heard that
they've given you their blessing which
is amazing to hear but has anyone
reached out personally not to us I mean
I think we're just we're in it we're
still in it yeah I'm still filming I you
know maybe something will happen when
when we air but I just think that even
like you we we got their blessing I mean
yeah we heard about that and that's
that's just such an honor
keeping a pretty close eye on it but
having that just makes you want to work
that much harder you know I want those
guys they poured so much of their lives
into those characters and I want them to
look at the mines and and say like yeah
like we passed on the baton and agree
well I'm excited to see the legacy
continued thank you guys so much for
sitting down with me enjoy your first
comic-con and say goodbye to the fans
well tell me